human toys red sky ou encore stone
belote
chaque groupe essaye de faire partager
son monde son univers un peu geek de
plus en plus nombreux au festival donne
first composition temps psychédélique
seventies saturation de la guitare
rythme très long très lent les babys
viper ont fait des déplacements depuis
perpignan
ils ont fait découvrir le titre de leur
dernier album c'est important pour nous
de se répandre en fait de mon petit peu
de se faire connaître un petit peu à
droite à gauche et puis de montrer un
petit peu cyniquement de quoi on est
capable
et voilà comme je les dis d'honorer
justement cet album nous avons senti et
dont nous sommes vraiment très fiers
pour la deuxième édition les
organisateurs de deuil first ont voulu
donner une dimension internationale et
festivals
contrairement à l'année dernière où
c'était beaucoup plus local je voulais
essayer de programmer un peu des exclus
et l'adisq a qui n'ont pas joué depuis
des années et ont joué une fois en
france c'était de chéticamp d'une 14
points en bretagne et depuis donc pas
rejouer études depuis et je trouvais ça
dommage parce que c'est vous qui est un
groupe qui fait un peu de la fusion avec
les croyances amérindienne des voix
ethnique et tout ça je trouvais ça super
intéressant et voilà ça super énergique
et voilà s'échauffent si c'est une
musique faut faire découvrir aux gens le
stoner attire les raids scalp ou
polonais ont des sonorités amérindiennes
avec des voix et nick nous nous trouvons
là où il ya des festivals internationaux
c'est sympa bien évidemment ils sont
très intéressants
mais nous aimons les deux les festivals
internationaux en pologne mais aussi les
groupes locaux
je pense qu en mixant les deux c'est la
meilleure façon
le métal a donc ses admirateurs dans les
yvelines un style musical en plein essor
qui attire de plus en plus d'adeptes
[Musique]